should we be choreographing our leg
thing here I like to do this well you
know you're each your own separate even
though you share sort of one mind for
the writing you're each your own
pursuits as we do whose mind are we
sharing they're ours if I were sharing
his mind you see the perforations on my
wrists ready
well you you're your own people for this
interview well don't you just do
whatever you want so actually we'll
we'll start with you then Jeffrey how
did you break into television no well
let's see
Oh a lot of this is gonna get cut right
edited and I think as long as there's no
names that are implicated okay well the
way I broke into TV is that you know my
father my uncle my first stepmother and
my stepfather were all in the industry
so I grew up around it and that meant I
knew pretty much everybody and now a
single one of them gave me a job at
first Peter laughs of my jobs I met my
first job was delivering call sheets at
Paramount which of course we don't do
anymore because everything is sent by
email then one of my dad's writing
partners it's a guy named Al Levitt his
real name was out Levitt he was
blacklisted he and his wife were
blacklisted and they wrote under the
name of Tom and Helen August and many
years later when the blacklist was over
and my dad was grey listed which meant
you were associated with yeah I don't
think I've told the story before that if
you were gray listed you were at some
point probably gonna be called before
the committee Wow
but his friends the levites after the
blacklist was over they were working on
an errand boys and long story they were
working on a Aaron Spelling show it was
the period when Love Boat was on which I
later worked on and Fantasy Island and
they wanted to do a show called I think
Aaron has sold a show called Paradise
Hotel
those days they would give you the pilot
script and six episodes and then they
would decide whether they were gonna
shoot it they didn't always shoot the
pilot so they gave me a script I had
never written television before I had I
think I tried to write a screenplay in
college not grad school because I was
going to be the great American novelist
and I got paid for it I got in the
writers guild and then ABC decided not
to make the show and that's was my first
job and then I met my writing partner my
long-term writing partner who had a lot
in common with because her uncles and
her grandfather were the Fleischer
brothers so Popeye Betty Boop out of the
inkwell and we worked together 12 years
and that's the partnership that
Hollywood likes the best is male-female
partners
next they like partners because they
like to meet him
they're getting two minds for the price
of one works so that's sort of my
background but I was around it all my
life
and why that was long-winded even by my
standards
you can cut around it up here Peter for
you joke writer when did you begin or
maybe that wasn't the yesterday well
surprisingly I came in from the academic
side and started studying the psychology
of humor and started doing research in
it and then I took some courses and
comedy writing and stand-up and got more
and more immersed and next thing you
know I was writing joke books we wrote a
few kids joke books they so pretty well
and then started writing nasty or adult
joke books and fun stuff and you have as
long as good as stories Jeffries well
you all something that is long you also
balance
your career moonlighting as a therapist
or psychologist well I started out as a
research psychologist later switched
over to were added clinical psychology
to it where I actually here's another in
a series of boring story since Jeffrey
started the tradition I I developed a
course called instructional humor which
was a course for public speakers and how
to use humor to get their point across
and in doing that I watched how nervous
students would get when they had to get
up and deliver anything is how I get
interested in stage fright okay
interesting is there is there room for
jokes when you're doing clinical
research amongst the colleagues or
that's where you got your material from
interestingly stories help people
remember things when I was a professor
anything I wanted students to remember I
had to come up with a clever or funny
example or clever funny story to get
them to remember the concept otherwise
so it's a it's a survival skill the way
the mind works it remembers stories
better than facts Oh interesting
explain so I'm sorry I'm just saying
that explains about history and science
for me sorry
have either of you tried stand-up I
think I remember you yes you had my
actually my first writing partner Julie
Fleischer had been in I don't know you
guys came here too late but the Kentucky
Fried theatre was sort of the thing of
the moment and they did improv shows
which were scripted actually I found out
later and then they would do some improv
with the audience and they were there
their parents take them the the guys who
made went on and made airplane later
sucker Abrams there were cousins and
brothers suckers brothers and
she and she went to work for them and
had long been an actress when I met her
she had been an actress and a stand-up
and one night she did convince me to go
to the to the comedy store and I it was
really bad I mean there's a gym break
people were asking for their money back
doesn't get worse than that no I had I
have no I wanted to be an actor when I
was in high school and I remember doing
I don't think I've told you this story I
think I was doing inherit the wind which
is you know the two main characters are
are based on William Jennings Bryan and
Clarence Darrow and they both have these
long speeches and I had to remember
memorize the speech from the Bible and I
went out halfway through it and drama
teacher said maybe not yeah I I think I
became a rut I think writers are very
often people who fail at everything else
so that's been my experience that you
know I did try a lot of other things and
yeah I or maybe they're comfortable in
their own element though that's a whole
nother is despite the fact that I love
to be around people I love being alone
in a room and I think you have to have
that too so you know Peters much more
sociable than I am so he's good in
crowds but I remember taking a stand-up
class and the first day the instructor
got up and said comedy is a really
aggressive art form you can't take it
get out it's kind of stuck with me hand
the cup of times I got up there and
tried it I said hmm harder than looks on
TV but my wife plays the accordion and
we have a we play in a group together
and I get to write the songs and genres
that accordion plays with an attempt to
make them be fun
and I get to do all the patter between
there which satisfies my need to do that
okay but again you feel comfortable
behind a typewriter or or computer is it
I as we say in Hollywood I go both ways
yes I I'm not sure how to answer that
[Laughter]